I'll not comment on it too much more
foreigner don't live here don't vote
here I do I do pay tax here more than
your current president does lag keep my
opinions to myself just because I'm very
aware that I'm not a I'm not a great
person I'm pretty not on the outside
great person up here
not good like some of the thoughts that
God in my head are genuinely evil and
they make me happy as well that's not
great like one of the things that makes
me laugh hardest in the world I've never
done this and I never will do this but
thinking about it makes me smile it's
just the idea of any child under the age
of 10 with an ice cream and just
tripping him up I've never done it I
never will but I'd be lying if I were to
say I didn't know detail by detail every
part of that endeavor I'd enjoy like
it's his birthday
he's got a big badge it says 9 on it
he's got a balloon it's all his favorite
flavors sprinkles ice cream sauce but
the thing is he's also a good big
brother and his little sister she's been
at home recently she's not been feeling
well and when he sees all this extra ice
cream his birthday the first thing he
does it's not take a broom to he wants
to run home and share it with her
and while he's running I'm just like ah
ha ha ha and because these young and
stupid he doesn't know whether to
prioritize his ice cream with a balloon
or his face and he screws all three up
in spectacular fashion just both flakes
both eyes ah does it not mail your heart
like his ice cream on the side of the
street
no but clearly some of you who could
agree and clearly some of you have
children that you love I just I've got
that voice in the back of me and I don't
trust people that don't have it because
it doesn't make you bad you've got to
control it like you've just got a good
person you see a kitten and no part of
your brain goes kick it like you don't
do but he's there I don't know why I
have this because my parents are great
people they like disgustingly in love
with each other they've been married
forever and like every morning my dad
wakes up and he rolls over and he looks
at my mama knee
he just can't believe his luck and she's
the same every morning she wakes up she
rolls over she looks up and she too
can't believe his luck
I've never been good in relationship
I've had some bad ones and these are
when some of the more evil thoughts come
in and I want to see if anyone can
relate to them you ever been in one of
those relationships we kind of just fall
out of love with the parson you don't
not like them you don't hate let me just
can stop loving them and it's a
difficult situation to be in because
that's not really a valid excuse for
breaking up with someone because it
makes you sound like a sociopath I'm
breaking up with you
why because I'm dead inside you used to
make me happy and now your smile makes
me sad so so you don't want to hurt them
so you just stay with them in the hopes
that you'll fall in love again
spoiler alert you won't it's dead but
then you just wait for them to do
something unforgivable so you can break
up with them and have the high ground
but they won't do that because unlike
you they're not a monster so then you
have to start lowering your standards
for what unforgivable is like one week
and you're like if they cheat at me
that's it it's over and I can leave with
my head held high and then they don't do
that and then three weeks later like man
if they buy orange juice with pulp in it
that is unforgivable and all I'm asking
is if you've ever been one of these
relationships where you're just trapped
and you feel like you can't get over it
have you ever even for the briefest of
moments have you ever accidentally
caught yourself thinking how much easier
life would be
if they were to just die no I'm not
because you want them dead but just
because they're dying is like the
easiest way for you to get out of that
relationship that doesn't involve either
one of you getting hurt emotionally love
me I'm not proud of that thought I'm not
proud of I'm not denying that I had and
I don't trust people that don't have
that voice there you've been in love
your whole life you've never had a
partner you hated just a poor even for
the previous moments they do something
that annoys you you storm out the house
they fornia their name appears on the
screen and it's only in that moment you
realize have stupid their name is you
know it's just a stupid name all the
idiots have that name and you don't want
to answer because you're angry but then
that voice in the back of your head goes
do it because this phone call might mean
that somebody somewhere has just found a
phone on a body
you've got to hide the disappointment
you've got to hide the disappointment in
your voice when they answer hello how
are you what are you up to oh you're
driving no I'll stay on the line yeah
what's up what is
you